oui il ya deux jours vraiment à
l'aéroport y est ma vie qui m'a dit cui
non non ah ouais ouais ouais bah vous
âmes ocha ah ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai je vais te dire c'est un truc
de fou que tu poses la question puisque
on m'a pris pour toi non marc étude de
juin jour à l'aéroport il ya un mec ki
moon a
convoqué un truc que tu dis tu passes
par la télé gertie media luna j'ai
toujours aéroports et me dit non
parce que moi aussi on m'a montré au
match aller c'est quoi c'est moi qui
fait qu'à balade champêtre un peu
600 malades
nous appris beaucoup au concours
c'est vrai que vous êtes un discours
je sais vous ah oui c'est à ces normes
beyoncé
en fait on appelle souvent isabelle
parce que des gens mais sinon j'ai pas
trop de nous alors quand je suis assis
lionel messi
[Rires]
mauvaises bases
parce qu'en fait on la comprend pas du
tout gênant ils la préparent depuis
trois ans ces salles se dit ouais je
crois que j'ai un bail à quoi mais là on
me dit a pris pour qui lionel messi
messi et eto'o sur le père fouras qca
arrête un peu quel est le même mais si
lionel messi et nicolas hulot très
souvent à nicolas nous
poussant un peu
c'est ça ton problème tu as ton problème
c'est ça tu as fais attention ça peut
être très vite un arrêt de carrière fais
gaffe à bout clara morgane non oui
un manga ouai ça me dirait series c'est
la mhealth malades
gelabale hilares
c'est pas
prêt pour qu'il vous alors moi quand
j'étais jeune julio iglesias ah ouais
mais vraiment ouais mais c'est même si
la question est maintenant endémique
non maintenant sabatier patrick sabatier
ah oui c'est très net c'est bizarre mais
pas trop si c'est la baisse à la bâtisse
est la même chez
xanaka chris evans mada voilà j'ai hâte
de savoir vous pourquoi qui abat oui
jean ping baril et christophe lambert
enfin non toi
christophe aubert directrice toi floués
[Applaudissements]
transformée sur la nature semble aussi
pas mal à des gens que j'adorais nous
sommes malheureusement quittés ya pas
longtemps ça oui notre choix est pas
vrai non mais franchement
ça me met alors j'étais malade ou quoi
non je n'ai pas dit ça mais alors c'est
un compliment il
a raison parce qu'ils seront jamais
parti pour moi ça voilà et la coiffure
c'est très beau
chantal et que jésus
et kiev te regarde il se dit ouais il
aime berger cherche des gens et m'a dit
dans les coulisses ça te va très bien
mais c'est vrai j'aime bien moi j'ai des
dames et moi et je te jure que ça et ça
illumine son visage soit jure que c'est
vrai il va bien je suis c'est beau de
d'assumer le temps qui parle
c'est avec mon émission
non franchement il est
super fort
ça va toi et valérie tu lui a pas
demandé à valérie chaussée saleri je
sais la chaîne et mme benkemoun
la synagogue
jeanine
normalement dans sa journée à beinheim
quatre à cinq fois moins
toute la journée ça c'est une pagaie
pense que je suis de la famille de
géraldine nakache non ah ouais ouais
ouais
vous n'êtes plus dans votre mairie de
oued de virages serrés comme ça vous
avez quelque chose de
ces métis demi siècle mais là il
martiaux s'il vous plaît